[Musique]
madame ça vous payez koala
un cadeau pour mon mari
et c'est votre argent c'est votre propre
carnet de chèques celui moment alors
vous fait des cadeaux à votre mari avec
son propre carnet de chèques comment est
ce qu'il fait il rit fille
ils vérifient les talents
enfin comme je n'ai pas exactement ce
que j'ai acheté qu'est ce que vous
mettez je sais pas je vais là par
exemple je crois que je vais mettre
vêtements pour enfants we look c'est un
cadeau pour lui
il croit que vous avez acheté les
vêtements pour vos enfants et ça ne
vérifie pas et il ya un cadeau et vous
le faites dans d'autres cas parfois ce
que vous truquez parfois son chéquier
dans le bas qu'ils soient au courant par
exemple je trouve ça plus facile de
procéder de cette façon là il ya
quelques années mon mari avait trouvé
une très bonne idée que j'ai collection
de pièces de 5 francs
alors les pièces de cinq francs c'est
quand il y en a beaucoup quand il y en a
quelques-unes ça vous a pas eu d'écoutés
pas tous les jours avec ça ça m'aidait
beaucoup en fin d'année madames kubrick
toujours la vérité à votre mari en ce
qui concerne l'argent les dépenses du
ménage
certaines fois mais pas toujours donnez
moi un exemple précis
médaillon de fleurs séchées c'est vous
dire qu'il coûte un certain prix je leur
présente et je les pays beaucoup plus
cher de nice 15 de vrais francs ou même
plus parfois lorsque je m'achetais
quelque chose de plus doux et votre mari
vous croire oui je pense que le fait de
mentir à son mari c'est un réflexe de
femmes ou colonisés et ça vous gêne pas
de gratter n'ont pas dû bien plus non
plus non c'est normal archi normal oui
c'est la vue oui c'est un fils crois que
toutes les femmes montrent un petit peu
mais j'ai toujours menti pour la bonne
cause à effets spéciaux k20 colle à la
bonne cause c'est mentir de pour obtenir
quelque chose enfin je peux vous donner
un exemple vous expliquer j'ai une bague
que j'aime beaucoup qui m'étaient
offertes par monsieur kima je crois il
met beaucoup alors j'étais très heureuse
d'avoir cette vague et comme j'avais
envie moi de lui faire un cadeau pour le
remercier de m'avoir offert ce cadeau je
me suis arrangé avec le bijoutier pour
qu'il me fasse une remise sur la bague
que m'avait commandé le monsieur en
question et avec l'argent qu'il va
donner gemmois commander chez le
bijoutier pour le monsieur qui fumait un
coupe cigare une pique à cigares et des
boutons de manchette assorti monsieur
chopin vous êtes ja alliés est ce qu'il
vous est déjà arrivé de te rencontrer
des femmes qui ne se conduisent pas de
manière tout à fait correct dans la
manière de se faire acheter un bijou il
est arrivé oui une ou deux fois que nous
ayons des choses qu'il nous on nous
mêmes étonnés et je pourrais vous citer
si vous voulez à titre d'anecdote bien
sûr parce que c'est rare un cas qui est
arrivé une fois par exemple c'est une
dame qui est venu et on lui a montré
différentes choses et dans les choses
qui me plaisait
bien c'était beaucoup plus que ce que le
monsieur qui l'accompagnait voulait
mettre est cependant celle chose l'huile
vraiment l'attenté énormément c'était
quoi c'était une bague avec saphir une
très jolie chose est une chose de grand
prix alors il fut décidé entre ce
monsieur est cette dame au petit
stratagème
la dame a proposé au monsieur de couper
la poire en deux si vous voulez et de
que le monsieur mettra une certaine
somme d'argent et que la seconde partie
de la somme d'argent serait mise par
elle-même seulement là où la chose
devient un peu plus rare c'est que par
la suite cette personne est revenue et
en disant monsieur ce n'est pas moi qui
vais mettre le complément de la somme
mais ce sera un autre monsieur qui va
venir et vous ferez comme si la chose
valait moitié prix et c'est lui qui
mettra l'autre sens tout s'est très bien
passé mais je dois dire que moi je
tremblais beaucoup parce que lapierre
étaient vendues soit disant à ce premier
monsieur et l'autre monsieur s'il
n'avait pas voulu acheter la pierre est
bien qu est ce qui me serait arrivé là
qu'hier était effectivement a vendu je
ne pouvais plus rien dire autrement dit
c'était moi qui payais la seconde partie
de la somme assez terne je dois dire que
tout aussi charmante que soit cette
personne je n'avais aucune raison de lui
payer cette bague est ce que vous pensez
votre femme avoue vous dis que j'en la
vérité en ce qui concerne l'utilisation
de l'argent du ménage sommes j'en suis
bien persuadé certainement
[Musique]